네 이런 얘기 들이게 좀 그렇지만
지금 부동산 경기는 저희에게 너무
[음악]
좋습니다 작심은 좀 많이들 아실 것
같은데 ing 스토리라는 회사를 좀
생소하게 느끼시는 분들도 계실 것
같아요 간단하게 소개를 해 주시면은
좋을 것 같은데요 단 ing 스토리는
말 그대로 진로교육 회사에서 최초에
시작이 되었기 때문에 현재 진행형의
이야기를 가지고 있는 다양한 분야에
있는 사람들을 중고등학교 학생들 에게
tvN 영화에서 나오는 의사 판사
변호사 검사 말고 열심히 살아가는
우리 동시대의 사람들이 들려줄 수
있는 이야기를 전해주는 취지로
만들어졌어요 회사 이름이 중간에 한번
피부 하다 보니까 제가 이거 회사를
폐업하고 다시 만들까 고민하다가이
회사를 잘 살려보자 해가지고 아지
스토리라 회사의 이름을 유지하게 된
거고요네 그래서 지금 하고 있는 일은
뭐냐면 스터디 카페로 시작을 했지만
저희가 공간 아이템들을 여러 개
가지고 있어요 대한민국 1등 브랜드
바버샵 브랜드 중 마시스트라 것도
최근에 인수했고 공유 창고 브랜드
마이 캐빈이는 것도 가지고 있고
그리고 저희가 시티 케이션이 아는
키즈 프라이비 카페도 가지고 있고
커피 언니라는 적각 커피 브랜드도
최근에 인수해서 운영하고 있는데요
이렇게 스터디 카페 독서실 가맹을
사업을 하다 보니 우리 스터디 카페
독서실을 운영하시는 점주님들이 건물주
분들이 어느 더 300분이 넘어가는
거예요 아 그러다 보니까 이런 다양한
테넌트들의 대한 수요가 있는 걸 알게
됐고 스터디 카페 말고도 도 1층에
들어갈 수 있는 테넌트 2층 3층에
또 다른 테넌트들의 추천받는 일들이
많아진 거예요 그러다 보니까 우리들이
공간에 들어갈 수 있는 테넌트들의
조금 더 잘할 수 있는 테넌트들의 좀
확보하게 됐고 더 나아가서 공간을
예약하는 시스템을 개발하는 it
회사를 가지고 있다 보니까이 두 개를
접목시켜 가지고 건물의 밸류를 올리고
건물의 밸류를 올려서 매각을 하게
되고 이런 시행사와 건설사들과
일하면서 수익률을 맞추는 어떻게
보면은 뭐 부동산 디벨로퍼 레이터
역할을 하는 회사로 운영이 되고 있는
회사가 ing 스토리입니다네 그러면
건물주 혹은 상가주 분들이 ing
스토리와 함께 할 수 있는 방안이
크게 직경 운영과 위탁 운용으로
나누어질 수 있다고 보면 될까요
맞습니다 요즘에 가장 추천하고 있는
거는 저희가 스터디 카페뿐만 아니라
이런 청담동에서 유명한 순수 브랜드의
감행 사업을 할 수 있는 권한을
가져와서 저희들이 매장을 또 넓히고
있고 건물주 분들 께서 건물에 대한
시설을 투자해 주시고 그리고 원하시는
수익률을 좀 조율 해서 우리들이
미니멈을 맞출 수 있는지 또는 이거는
수수료를 얼마를 하면 우리에게 서로
양상 관이 좋은지 이런 것들을
따져보고 건물의 입점해 1등
브랜드들을 넣어서 밸류를 업해서 뭐
매각하려는 분도 있고 또는 이걸 운영
수익으로 운영하시다가 상속하는 분도
계시고 이런 다양한 건물주 분들과
솔루션을 같이 좀 풀어 가는 예 그런
일들 많이 하고 있습니다 건물주
분들의 입장에서는 월세 수익을 받느냐
아니면 그 수익률의 일부 퍼센테이지를
받느냐 이렇게 두 가지로 나뉘는데
아무래도 월세 수익을 받다 보면은
임차인 분들의 그 사업 흐름에는
관계없이 매달 똑같은 임대료가 지급이
되게 되는데 수익이 일부를 쉐어
받으면 사업이 잘 운영이 안 됐을
경우에 리스크를지게 될 수도 있잖아요
혹시 그런 점에 대해서는 리스크가
크지는 않은지 그게 궁금합니다데 항상
이렇게 얘기 드려요 그 원하는 임대료
를 그냥 월세를 받게 되면 제일
좋지만 결국에 그 운영하는 그
사업자가 잘 안 되면 그또한 공실이
남게 되고 임대료를 못내는 상황들도
벌어지는데 우리들 대부분이 대로변에
엄청 좋은 메인 건물을 갖고 있는게
아니잖아요 그 면도에 있는 꼬마
빌딩들이 그가 한 블록 더 들어가고
또 여기에서 또 떨어져 있고 주거
밀집 지역이라 그가 상가라 그가 이런
미분양 갖고 있다면 건축비도 올라가고
이런 공실이 높아지다 보면이자
부담들이 많단 말이죠 언제까지 월세
내가 기다리다 보면은 그런 부분들이
또 부담이 될 수도 있고 그런
분들께서 차라리 이자를 계산해 보고
2년치 1년치를 계산해 보고 운영
수익을 좀 더 중요시 할 건지 일부층
임대 주고 일부층 운영 수익으로
안정적으로 운영해 나갈 건지 어떤
분이 만약에 통 건물을
임대했고 어려워졌다고 임대를 갑자기
임대를 안 내면네 이분 입장에서 명도
소송하는 시간도 걸리고 임대료도 못내
못 받고 보증금 보증금대출
이렇게 됐었을 때 또 더 큰 저는
위험이 있다고 생각을 하거든요네
그래서 그런 복합적인 것들을 고려해
보고 저희들 같이 하는 건물주 분들이
상당히 많아졌고 그래서 꼬마 빌딩들
문의는 정말 많은 상황입니다 신도시
건물들 이런 건 당연히 너무 많고
저희가 다 못 들어갈 정도로 많이
오고 있습니다네 이런 얘기 들이긴 좀
그렇지만 지금 부동산 경기는 저희에게
너무 좋습니다 아 정말 좋은 기회의
건물들 좋은 건물들 건물주 분들
신사분들 만나서 정말 어 앞으로 2
3년 뒤에는 저희 회사가 되게 좋은
포트폴리오 건물들을 많이 보유하면서
운영 수익도 많이 낼 거 같아요 어
내 너무 기대되는데요네 그럼 다른
업체들과 달리 ing 스토리만이
가지는 차별성이 있다면 어떤게
있을까요 다른 곳을 어떻게 운영하는지
모르겠지만 저희는 일단 가지고 있는
브랜드 자체가 업계에서 인지도가
상당히 높은 1등 브랜드들을 일단
많이 가지고 있고 많잖아요 운영
수익률이 중요한 사람들도 있고네 어떤
건물주분 만났더니 나 임대 안 나가도
돼 근데 맞나 치는 거 들어왔으면
좋겠어 1등 브랜드 그래서 난
마제스티 이거 백화점에 들어가고
현대자동차 기아 본사에도 들어가 있고
현대 카드에도 본사에도 들어가 있는
브랜드다 보니까 나는 이런 브랜드가
그냥 내 건물 1층에 들어왔으면
좋겠어 압구 정동에서 그러면 그냥
브랜드 그냥 넣는 거거든요 이제는
선택은 저희가 하겠지만 그런 건물주
분들도 분명히 존재하다 보니 저희가
차별이 뭐냐면 어쨌든 유명한 테넌트
건물들 많이 갖고 있다 fmb 말고네
뭐 fmb 하고 있지만 저희는 그
외에 어 fmb 다도 조금 더 더
세련된 브랜드를 가지고 있는게 좀
메리트인 거 같고 또 하나는 전국에
한 1,000개 정도로 매장을 오픈해
보니까 저희들이 어떤 상권이 잘되고
어떤 상권이 좀 힘들고 그런 데이터가
되게 많아요네 그 데이터를 가지고
있는 거 자체만으로도 성공확률을 높일
수 있기 때문에 단순히 뭐 다른 데서
뭐 조금 더 매장을 뭐 몇십 배 갖고
있고 이런 데랑 저희랑 비교할 건
아니라고
봐요음 말씀을 듣다 보니까 되게
데이터를 기반으로 해서 사업를
추진하시는게 굉장히 좀 멋있게
들리는데요 대표님 해야 되는데 그렇게
하고 싶어도 못하죠 매장을 내본
경험도 없고 열정과 의지는 충만하지만
공간을 많이 오픈해 본 적도 없는
분들이 막 공간 컨설팅하고 막
그러잖아요 저희가 볼 땐 그게
되게 뭐지 막 이런 생각이 드는
거죠데 저희는 천개를 오픈해 봤고
3,300개 넘는 곳에 독서실
스터디가뿐만 아니라 공유 오피스부터
공유
창고부지 바보사 이런 등등등의
소프트웨어를 저희들이 공급하고 있다
보니까 어디 잘 되고 어디가 안 되고
어디를 어떻게 해야 되는지를 그래도
그들보다 더 잘 알고 있다 보니까
당연히 저희가 성공할 수 확률이 높은
거죠 시간이 가면 갈수록 시간 우리
편인 거죠네 그런 자료들이 뒷받침되다
보니까 함께 하시는 분들도 더 믿고
진행하실 수 있겠네요 빈님 그럼요네
그 그게 차별 이니다네 감사합니다
제가 대화를 나누다 보니까 대표님께서
사업을 이렇게 운영하심 있어서
중요하게 생각하시는 점이 무엇인지가
갑자기 궁금해져 가지고요 저는 우리
영업 조직이 우리 회사에서 제 직속
부어요네 막 이렇게 밑에 있고 그렇지
않고 제가 다이렉트로 교육을 하는데
항상 얘기하는게 미팅을 오래할 필요
없다 왜냐면 솔직하게 얘기하면 우리는
미팅이 효율적으로 서로에게 도움이
되는 방향으로 계약이 잘 될 수 있다
저 항상 이렇게 얘기를 해요 진실함이
진짜 중요한데네이 사람이 진짜로 돈이
있는지 없는지 우린 몰라요 근데
대화를 여러 번 하다 보면 돈이 없는
거를 알게 되고 또는 돈이 많은
사실도 나중에 알게 되고 진솔하게
대화를 했다면 서로에게 필요한 니즈를
빨리 파악하고 빠른 솔루션으로 시간을
조력하고 할 수 있는데 이런 부분들이
일하면서 제가 많이 느끼거든요 그래서
저는 제일 중요한 거는 그냥 처음부터
솔직한 대화 우리도 마찬가지고 상대도
마찬가지고 그렇게 하면 일이 잘 되는
거 같습니다 어네 너무 좋은 답변
감사합니다 마지막으로 ing 스토리
앞으로의 사업 방향과 목표가 있다면
공유해 주시면 감사할 것 같습니다
저희는 앞으로도 계속 1등 테넌트들의
좀 발굴을 많이 할 거고요 지금
가지고 있는 브랜드들을 더 잘 될 수
있도록 브랜딩하고 그리고 저희가
들어갈 건물들 그리고 입점할 건물들에
대해서 수익률 높일 수 있도록
집중하는게 저희들이 지금 당장 해야
할 일이라고 생각을 하고요 시간이
지나면 지날수록 아까 말씀드린 대로
그 소프트웨어들 그 즉 그 혈관들이
많이 깔리게 되면 저희들은 데이터가
더 많아질 것이고 저희들이 들어갈
건물들은 더 수익률이 잘 나올 거라고
확신합니다 양쪽에서 우리들은 기술과
공간 사업을 잘 펼쳐 나가서
대한민국에서 그래도 PM 역할도
하면서 오퍼레이션 가능한 그런 회사가
되는게네 목표입니다 답 너무
감사합니다 어떤 컨텐츠로 건물을 채워
놨는지 건물의 가치와 직결되는데요
공실이 걱정될 땐 무조건 작심을
넣으세요 라기보다는 건물을 운영함에
있어 이런 방법도 있다는 것을
말씀드리고 싶었습니다 내 건물에
해봤을 때 괜찮겠다 혹은 괜찮을까
고민이 되실 땐 강남구 대표님의
ing 스토리에 도움을 구해 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 맞죠 대표님 응
맞습니다 원하시는 분들은 저희 쪽에
연락 주시면 연결 도와드리도록
하겠습니다 그럼 오늘 영상도 즐겁고
유익하였습니다
감사합니다 아
감사합니다 e